many people don't have an opinion until
they ask for it at which point they
Cobble together a Viewpoint from whim
and half remembered hearsay before
deciding that this two minute old
makeshift opinion will be their new Hill
to die on brilliant makes a lot of sense
around why seemingly unsophisticated
viewpoints by people that kind of
skeptical or critical about the depth of
thought that they've put into it the
only way that I could get myself to a
place where I am that certain about
anything would be if I was completely
bulletproof I've done all of the
research I know everything front to back
I got all of the examples of the counter
arguments that the opponents would say
about it everything it becomes easy for
us to believe that other people's views
are more sophisticated than they are
this comes to something I've Loved for a
long time which is strong opinions
loosely held not loose opinion strongly
held if you don't really know what
you're talking about and yet you're
going to die in order to save it that's
a stupid position you should be open to
changing your mind almost at all times